hello Daniel do I hear at Gamescom 2014
I'm joined by Sean McGuinness hey Danny
how are you doing my friend
I'm doing quite well right here we're
looking at some original gameplay that
we shot at the ubisoft booth this is you
it's growing meat of people in the
Himalayas this is me playing right now
you'll notice immediately the first
thing I did was throw some meat and what
it's done actually is you can't see it
it's kind of obscured by Matt Rock right
there but there's actually a Snow
Leopard that's come to attack these guys
nice that's all that's why they've all
kind of like jumped into into this kind
of crazy situation here where they're
kind of firing at some unseen force off
in the distance so this is a level that
I'm we played a couple of days ago that
basically is a it's kind of like an
instance level up in the mountains all
this himalaya stuff is you you get the
emission marker and I guess there's a
bunch of different ways as is the you
know Far Cry motifs operon day of like
getting in there and getting your
assassination target assume that who's
in that building but you have the meat
stuff it you can kind of use it to as
much as fun it is to throw me to people
and get animals to attack them you can
also use it as a kind of a diversionary
tactic when you're stealth in right oh
it's great yeah I mean you don't have to
use it to like kill guards although it's
obviously very handy for that as well
like here I'm just kind of having fun
with it
purely for the sake of games like after
I would actually want to see what see
what happens to this guy if I recall
correctly I yeah that happens oh great
loading barrows far cry 4 confront go in
there but the meat is cool because you
just switch from grenades to meat and
then you throw the meat oh yeah so this
is a bear yeah so the Bears are
attracted to the smell of the meat the
developers told me that generally it
animals in the area okay you got a good
talk plated yeah it's Barrett's you wait
all day for a bear and then to turn over
the same time it'll actually spawn
nearby animals if there are Teddy oh you
got to make to close down and don't you
gotta be too close to you I love this
shotgun right here it's it's pretty sue
yeah it's got decent range on as well -
I liked how when they get we went
through this mission you have to kind of
them wait are you gonna you know make
I'm gonna make more bait out of that
bear that's kind of awful yeah I love
how you had like a selection of
long-range edger your silence has gone
as well your Z's you kind of threw the
self you see you guys skin that guy as
well like I'm let's get you're gonna
skin not guys she's gonna pop up a
couple times so down this way I'm
actually gonna go wait first there we go
pretty good job not bad
so these are actually yak oh my god yeah
the yaks are not predators like the
Bears and snow leopards so they are not
attracted to bait but it gonna do mess
around with them they will charge you I
was trying to kite them along to attack
some more enemies yeah but the yaks
weren't having any any shame hopefully
the modded some of the mod V PC version
of Far Cry 4 so that the acts are in
fact better oh you're gonna skin that
Snow Leopard yeah why not
I mean Thomas that meat is perfectly
good you're gonna be over encumbered
with various meats from the animal
kingdom pretty soon
what's that was that a dog little
mountain goat fingers ran by and just
kind of sneaking around the guy saw me
over on the other side so I'm gonna
sneak around open
take them out album Papa you know
sweetheart election had last night yeah
I did you enjoy playing this level you
just serve some meat I had so liked the
new meat bait mechanic is so much fun
good shop ok Network we're going into a
this is the e3 demo at a rut Oh g'day
hey which I played and obviously and
this is something I told you to do which
was get follow me the monkeys didn't
work they're a little scared I asked the
producer there how many people at the
start of this demo instantly and
grenade-launcher those monkeys
he said about 95 seconds that sounds
about right and then he said only about
5% shoot the elephants oh really yeah
which is very reassuring that's nice
yeah not not for the monkey Kingdom
protected oh yeah my needs for monkeys
but elephants are majestic creatures so
this is the I had done this demo about
20 times up until this point and had so
much fun like dying and then respawning
and playing it again and this was the
first time I attempted stealth because
there's one of those gyrocopters behind
you start with the M I'm just throwing
me to people like I think at this stage
you were just saying throw me to throw
me yeah so I continued you can see my
play style rubbing off on yours at this
point this dude jumps off the building
so nonchalantly look at is like BAM no
problem so I like you said when you
throw the meet at tens I guess if
there's no animal nearby it'll just kind
of spawn one and I can hear you guys
what sounds like some sort of tiger or
lion and the background throw some more
meat down there one thing I do want to
point out is that unlike the rocks in
the game the meat is a finite right
resource yes so you can actually see in
the corner you've got three hunks of
meat in your magical meat bag right now
I know these guys are shooting at I
believe a snow leopard that's appeared
over to the left so I'm like I'm using
that there's they're all getting got
their attention over there they could
actually just killed it there and I'm
gonna send the sneak on over here I've
got these M as silenced little mini
machine gun here it's got d6 written on
it for some reason this guy's gonna
yes I oxy think I accidentally hit the
Beehive in the background there so now
all the bees are on me God not the bees
you can if the enemies go near to
beehive you can shoot it in little it'll
attack them that's funny
and now at this stage I'm kind of I'm
not sure I'm like do I do I sneaking
around the back and try and kill these
guys or there's a lot of them kind of
exposed and I'm not reassure what to do
but that's the kind of cool thing about
far cry is it at that moment a moment
like yeah dynamic game player you just
kind of you don't know how the different
systems are going to interact with each
other just like the reason all that
stuff in Far Cry 3 was talking so much
fun oh yeah you know it pretty similar
here so yeah I throw me they throw a
grenade and I realize that maybe perhaps
a stealth option isn't the best idea
here so I booked it back to my good
friend the gyrocopter
oh yeah which is pretty sweet you can
shoot when you're using this thing so
you could just like I could hear like
Ryder the batteries in my ear I guess
I'm like doing this shot that much yeah
you can just like grenade launch of
people to bits it's great fun
this was the e3 demo I absolutely adored
it and it did nothing but to make me
more excited for far cry 4 finally this
is a level you play this is shangri-la
shangri-la this is the kind of sort of
like palate cleanser missions of the
game I guess the alternate spirit realm
I mean every first-person shooter has to
have those alternate spirit realm
missions right
that section
so the biggest difference is that you've
got that white tiger you can see it just
yet but you will see in a hot minute so
you pressing r1 you can actually sick
the tiger on two people right and it's
great right here because that guy with
the mystical flamethrower he's a heavy
and you can only kill him from behind I
kind of messed up here I went for the
slash when I should have gone for the
contextual oh yeah take down attack but
the tiger is so much fun oh my god it
cut cloaks as well so if you're if
you're stuffing and you tell it to kill
somebody and you don't wanna get seen
it'll it'll cloak and try and finish
them off without alerting everyone else
yeah and instead of syringes you have to
unsnap you're broken right hand bones
kind of a fun return to farcry of old
yeah it this one I read through pretty
quickly because I played it before but
you're right it is much more linear than
far cry 4 would normally be and I think
that's probably the reason that I'm not
super in love with it because I love the
openness and the ability to approach
situations from all kinds of angles and
you like the exploding mystical dogs
yeah the exploding mystical dogs are
pretty great I mean so far it's just
like these basic human enemies which you
can shoot with your with your bow and
arrow which slows down time a little bit
and then you have the heavy guys I
didn't encounter any other enemies
besides like well I guess there are the
exploding dogs and there's that I should
point that out um but yeah I definitely
preferred you know vanilla far cry 4 I'm
curious just like how many of these
missions there's gonna be like and how
just you know how much they're gonna
keep with the pacing of the game yeah
like what variety I guess cuz they're
you know it is kind of a little bit
jarring to go from this kind of open
area to these kind of linear ones but I
guess that's probably why they're
optional apparently you can access them
via and paintings within the world I
just see some sick painting and then you
jump into painting and I wonder if
there's some sort of psychedelics
involved this is a far cry game ago
you're gonna hit shut that dude that's
pretty good this lowdown time there yeah
oh the boats not in time yeah when
you're when you're aiming there slash
it's pretty sick um so yeah I'm sticking
the tiger under that guy right there and
then at this point there's like there's
a bunch of enemies and we're a little
bit rushed for time so I just said screw
it I'm running for the Bell of
enlightenment I can't wait for
enlightenment I need to seize it right
now the color palette is pretty great
yeah I think usually these levels look
really really cool and one interesting
thing is that these sections are
actually made by Ubisoft Toronto studio
okay whereas the main game is made by
Montreal of course this game is being
made of course by seven million people
seven million different different people
across 30 million studios
Madlock she sucking less before Tanaka
oh yeah I had a blast I can't wait for
it to go chop it off there we go
I'm enlightened it there you go it's the
bell end okay
this is the bell end of the video guys